welcome back to CBS mornings the White
House has told all federal workers did
it just yesterday that they have 30 days
to stop using tick tock on
government-issued devices Congress
approved that ban arguing that the
chinese-owned app is a security risk and
the bite Administration is also asking
big tech companies to stop using
software linked to cyber attacks on
critical American infrastructure at the
same time a new report from security
firm crowdstrike tracked more than 200
cyber crime adversaries in 2022 that is
its most ever the global threat report
analyzed the tax from a dozen nation
states also so-called hacktivist groups
and also organized crime Sean Henry is
crowdstrike's Chief security officer and
he joins us now uh Sean thank you very
much for being here thanks for having me
it's an eye-opening report and I do want
to dig into it but since the news is
this 30-day warning on tick tock on
government devices
I'd love to know how big of a threat or
risk is Tick Tock in your view well
China wants to be the number one
superpower in the world and they have
been targeting U.S technology U.S
personal information they've been doing
electronic Espionage for several decades
now Tick Tock is just another activity
another opportunity for them to gain
access to people's information to see
what people are thinking about to
potentially influence the way people
think by putting misinformation into
their app and the U.S concerns about
Tick Tock and it's not just the us but
the broader Western world are absolutely
valid do you think it's wise of Congress
to uh have approved this ban at one
Congressman called it like putting a spy
balloon on your phone well I think
that's an interesting metaphor uh
probably not so far off it's important
to understand who the adversaries are
what their objectives are and the many
different techniques they'll use to
achieve their objectives this is one of
those ways what about tick tock on your
kids phones why should we care about
that I think you're on your kids phones
China plays the long game and the kids
teenagers today a in 10 years are going
to be adults they're going to be in
universities they're going to be in
working in major corporations around
around the country around the world and
to collect intelligence now to
potentially use long-term down the road
that's a big long game though Sean it's
absolutely a long game but you know
Chinese government has been in place for
many many years there's a lot of
consistency they have a very clear
strategy they're going to execute on
that strategy to achieve their
objectives that's a very good question
and I want to follow up on that you know
moment of full transparency I have Tick
Tock people told me hey create one
that's great for Branding my wife has it
she does things professionally and then
each of my kids 18 16 and 12. so when I
hear that it's banned on government
devices I think there's a lot of people
at home that are sitting back thinking
well should I erase this app should I
continue to use it is it a casual app
just like any other social media
platform what is your answer to that I
think it's important for everybody to
understand the way social media is
utilized and when people push
information onto the network that it
stays there forever when you're looking
at how is it collected who has access
what might they be doing with that data
long term that's changes the calculus
and I think that has to factor in to the
type of applications that you use and
the type of information that you put
into those applications how effective
has cyber attacks been on the us because
we hear cyber attacks but we don't know
what's going on behind the scenes yeah
there there are uh multiple nation
states that are using this as a tool of
their digital exploitation part of their
intelligence collection they're looking
to influence American citizens they're
looking to collect data about sensitive
technology military operations but
personal information about individuals
as well so that they can exploit those
to again achieve their their objectives
the targeting of critical infrastructure
is absolutely serious we're looking at
communications energy Transportation
where adversaries are trying to gain
access so that they can collect and also
potentially disrupt but they're very
creative and very smart the adversaries
I've heard you describe this as an an
instrument of War what do you mean by
that an instrument of War well this is
now a tool or a weapon in the Arsenal of
every nation state in advance of
tactical military maneues for example
what we saw in Ukraine Russia in advance
of rolling tanks across the border
targeted Ukrainian critical
infrastructure things like communication
the electric power grid they pushed
misinformation out to try and cause
confusion and create Havoc within the
Ukrainian citizenry I think that this is
now part of the Playbook long term it's
something that everybody needs to
consider it's not just tactical it's not
physical but there's this whole virtual
and digital component that everybody
needs to be concerned about do you have
a sense of what Putin's my next move
could be from a cyber security point of
view I I think the Russians have been
very very good about using this tool saw
it in in advance of the Ukraine attack
going forward I think as more tactical
Maneuvers more military operations
continue in the springtime we're going
to see it used more often again critical
infrastructure Transportation
Communications Logistics supply chain
Etc by disrupting those things it makes
it much more difficult from a physical
response to to engage so I think that's
something we need to be concerned we
focus on China and Russia but do you
think it's so much bigger than that and
then I look at my you know there was a
story yesterday about the iPhone
security the iPhone I think what do I
need to do about that you say this
picture is so much bigger than our
iPhones and it's bigger than China and
Russia is it not it is the activist
group's an organized crimes absolutely
we we have seen major companies that
have been disrupted for weeks or months
parts of their operation Whole cities
that have been shut down and forced to
go back to pen and paper we've seen
electric power grid targeted we've seen
oil pipelines targeted water
infrastructure these are everything that
we do is connected to the network the
adversaries know that their ability to
disrupt or destroy that type of
infrastructure from organized crime
perspective they're doing it for
financial gain from a nation-state
perspective they're collecting
intelligence and causing an impact on
our society so this is John so what do
we do I think first of all citizens I've
talked to lots of boards of directors uh
uh corporate Executives making sure they
understand what the risk is and how do
you mitigate the risk what are the
strategies you employ from a tactical
perspective technical perspective it's
making sure you're constantly monitoring
your networks looking for indicators of
anomalous Behavior so you can detect and
disrupt those those types of behavior
yeah we got to go but doing a commercial
break I want to ask you about artificial
intelligence because it's been a Hot
Topic yeah big topic as well Sean Henry
thank you so much thank you very much